friends of the internet first and
foremost thank you for giving me enough
content to make another video here we
are told my Avengers end game trailer
video I [ __ ] up some information how
did that happen I'll tell you exactly
how it happened but first I'm gonna
course-correct I'm gonna write the wrong
[ __ ] up number 1 Scott Lang I don't know
I said they're big Scott Lang fans they
want an autograph
I think that's legit if you can't tell
them making jokes that's kind of what I
do here I don't necessarily give you
exact information how it's supposed to
be I kind of just poke fun at things so
that kind of hypothesize as to why he
might be there and why they might be
surprised and all right maybe it was
reaching but it's just fun to talk about
that [ __ ] online moving on number 2
nebula left Tony Stark there to die but
not she's in the ship right there that's
true nebula isn't a ship could be the
ship she took off in to leave him there
most likely it's the same ship that Tony
Stark's head fine I admit that an
oversight on my part but he's starving
to death so he's totally gonna eat her
Danny's gonna cannibalize her seriously
though they're totally gonna [ __ ] like
stranded in the middle of nowhere gonna
die with the hot cyborg chick like
that's a fantasy I'm not the only one
right he's totally smashing some cyber
chairs and the biggest transgression of
them all it's a skirt from alright so
Thanos took his armor any made a
scarecrow out of it hole directly from
the graphic novel but is it a scarecrow
I mean if you look at that shot of the
Scarecrow from the comic the arms are
down in the movie trailer the arms are
up so is it really a scarecrow like the
comic books is it the same thing I say
nay and you think about the logistics
you think about it logically he's there
he's hanging out he's doing his
gardening he's a farmer he's working his
home not like Tony Stark well he's
stranded no no like farmer grimace wood
he's lonely there he's bored he want
some entertainment what to do so is that
a scarecrow or is that Thanos trying to
put on a one-man production of Passion
of the Christ just the arms are down in
the comic book the arms are up in the
movie could be one of many things not a
scarecrow like a yoga pose Wallace from
Wallace and Gromit
those [ __ ] inflatable tube [ __ ] from
used-car Lots Michael Scott as Michael
Klump William Wallace this baby Bono
rose from Titanic Jack from Titanic
Christian band album cover Christ the
Redeemer Kim Kardashian doing Christ the
Redeemer in front of Christ the Redeemer
Kim Kardashian and Kanye Kardashian
doing Christ the Redeemer in front of
Christ the Redeemer ezio me with no
pants on Barack Obama Donald Trump a dog
in a gingerbread costume this baby
penguin han Solo
gregor hulk hogan marilyn manson a
snowman Jim Morrison and Tony Stark
because he hopes we remember him hope
they remember you and we will so I urge
you to think of that [ __ ] but to the
point how oh how did I not know that
then was turned his armor into a
scarecrow in the comic books some people
seem pretty perplexed about that very
simple we're going Occam's razor on this
never wrote the comic book but I enjoy
comic books I read them I just haven't
read all of them even some of the
staples like Infinity Gauntlet Slayer
they slipped through the crack do you
think snap and I did a segment called
comic book shopping in which he informed
me about comic books because I know all
about him now is that that would be
weird if we're both like yeah we're
gurus we know everything but please act
like you're teaching me something about
I try to give it real I don't want fact
checkers I don't want to be a little
good totally know everything because I
googled act like I knew it for years if
not decades because you have to I don't
be like that being complete it's more
fun you always have something to strive
for some people might find that weird I
just I can't watch play see or hear
everything in entertainment that's just
impossible it's not gonna happen like
some of the indie obscure comic books or
some of the cooler ones I've read
they're not gonna be made into movies
anytime soon because they're not you
know huge I'm a little too eccentric
when you hit your light that's not
actually next to your head my comment
section so we can calm down now
his Scarecrow please so kill me I
suppose I'm doing this not only just a
kind of fun with it but to inform you to
solidify the fact that when this happens
again and I do mean when when I [ __ ] up
information again don't let it freak you
out too much I'm pretty down with my
legacy of kain lore and lines from the
Van Damme street fighter so if I [ __ ] up
those feel free to be surprised hope you
enjoyed this video hope you're having
fun with it that's what we're on YouTube
for to have fun but Tony Stark and
nebula are totally gonna [ __ ] I'm
serious about that that's in the comic
books though I don't suggest searching
for that it's out there you could find
it but that's fanfiction they do things
there I mean if you google search for
venom and spider-gwen I can't stop you I
can't stop you from google searching
that but you're gonna say some [ __ ] but
what's a comic book that people have
told you you should read that you
haven't read or maybe it's a video game
people have said you should play that
you haven't played or or a movie that
you should watch that you have a watch
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here
just anymore
[Music]